Dark prior to says how can you dispute
the theory that Jesus is just a rewrite
of the Sun God myth?
Well,
I wouldn't necessarily
dispute that theory.
Um,
although I would dispute the just,
I mean the strange things
about the biblical stories
and let's say about the new
testament stories is that they echo
across multiple levels of analysis.
And so there is an astrological
element to the Christ story.
Um,
that Yo wrote about a fair
bit in the book called Ion,
which is a very terrifying book.
And there are examples of
the myths of the Sun God.
And,
but the funny thing is,
and this is one of the things I can't
really understand about the biblical
stories,
is that they manifest themselves at
multiple levels of interpretation
simultaneously.
And you could say that that's merely
a consequence of continual historical
reworking.
And I suppose that could be the case,
but the fact that they manifest themselves
as a personal story and as a cosmic
story and as a historical story and as
a mythological story and that it all
works at the same time strikes me as,
as pointing to something that's really
somewhat beyond our current level of
understanding.
Um,
again,
to elaborate on that a lot because it
would take us into places that I really
would rather not go,
but I do believe that like there's
something synchronous using Young's
terminology about the,
about death and resurrection story.
And the syncronous element is,
is associated with the fact that the
story echoes across so many levels of
analysis.
And my sense is that when something
echoes across many levels of analysis,
that means that it's approaching
something like a very deep truth.
So I know that isn't normally how we
go about determining what constitutes
truth,
but we don't know everything about how
to determine what constitutes truth yet.
And there are many things that
we have yet to figure out,
can that,
certainly one of them,
as far as I'm concerned.
So there is a Sun God myth element,
certainly parallels
between Christ and Horace,
for example.
But,
um,
that doesn't mean you can
just say it's just a rewrite.
Um,
I don't think that the,
I don't think that that's historically
or a psychologically accurate.
Um.